hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
this is John come on ray Humphrey we're
gonna watch The Joker battle by mutti
raccoon Heath Ledger versus Joaquin
Phoenix versus the Clown Prince the ball
ooh the Battle of the clowns I'm so
excited my raccoons videos are awesome
if you have not subscribed a mighty
raccoon D gotta do it as soon as
possible
Jared Leto is definitely not gonna win
let's watch a little bit of Jerry little
that'd be the definition of subverting
expectations
that's what Joker's all about oh here we
go oh so it definitely passed a new
YouTube uploader yes for kids yeah
they look this light grungy look Scouts
Robin on his team Batman on
[Music]
he's doing their dark-eyed things oh yes
why
Dan's eyes are dilated massive and yeah
it's bigger than his face
dear you barely smoke that cigarette No
it's a waste
to save the rest of the luck the Hammers
this
[Music]
yep
[Music]
this shop I grabbed that revolver
[Music]
you're giving up for one nice good
vision vision issues team up and for me
[Music]
mommy gets the kitchen I would defend
herself he doesn't like that
not one bit so me while she does
he turns to me why
[Music]
or spar camels Joker
[Music]
please do guys like share and subscribe
to the mighty raccoon of course Joker by
Sherrod did not win I'm so bummed I was
on Team Jared yeah that's so hard I got
my damage tattoo I don't I don't it's
weird because I definitely think the
best Joker is Heath Ledger's Joker we've
had this discussion many times at a
reactional WatchMojo video I was on
screen junkies movie fights and I
pitched why I think Heath Ledger is the
best live-action Joker we've ever gotten
even though I loved the Arthur Fleck
character
kudos to Joaquin Phoenix did an amazing
job Jared Leto getting killed off like
yeah that is how it should have gone a
nice Logan Harvey then when he got to
this mode with Heath Ledger walking
Phoenix when walking in Phoenix we kind
of bump about like I think Heath Ledger
is the best one but I actually kind of
didn't want to see that happen to know
it's gonna hoping they just like make
out or something yeah yeah hold hands
and skip out of the building you know
into a world of crime but yeah I was
hoping they would team up or something
but you know a Keane capped off Jared
Leto which clearly you know Heath Ledger
either wanted for himself or you know
wasn't ready for just yet yeah yeah I
had to go mighty raccoon usually does
these battle videos and whatnot but I
think it'd be fun if he actually put
something together where they're just
interacting with each other yeah I just
have like talking with it
yeah hypothetical scenes you've always
wanted to see your son that'll be fun
add some character stakes to it as
opposed to just who's gonna win in a
fight you know yeah because like Joker's
battling each other is not much you can
really do there's the Joker's not known
for fighting skills that's like yeah
this is about what it was gonna be like
peacocking and get himself killed Dow
and then yeah Joaquin Phoenix isn't
gonna do something unpredictable and
Heath Ledger's got the whole situation
under control
but I like the you know he clearly knows
his Joker's like you would have those
guys in the mess like in Suicide Squad
having the Batman match
as his bodyguards Jared Leto Heath
Ledger using his knife of course and
then even with like Joaquin Phoenix is
showing up and you want to hear a joke
or my bad that he shows up when he just
shoots a gun he doesn't even say
anything yeah that's that's about in
tune with all the characters and kudos
and for the animation too as well like
this is hard to put together ideally I
feel like in the perfect world you'd
probably spend like a year or something
something like this to make it look
perfect but you got to do what's hot it
what's trending right now I wonder if in
the comments people are like pissed
about the outcome of the winner yeah
yeah people were putting money on this
man a lot of people lost a lot had to go
into bankruptcy foreclosure you know
move out of their homes and stuff it's
been really bad
I think the joaquin phoenix voice is
good the Heath Ledger voice is great I'm
pretty sure there were times I just
pulled directly from the movie just put
the audio there the chair little voice
exactly is the Jared Leto voice oh
that's a great question I feel like it's
somewhere in between them because it has
that sort of like soft amber that
matches closer to Joaquin but with the
drolly nasal mists of Heath Ledger like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] or whatever you know
I'm just gonna hurt your real really
feel like he's just like putting more
breath in it pretty good thing Thanks
thanks man I'm cornering the market on
the most hated Joker impression well
dude I'm gonna just make it even harder
for you right now guys subscribe to
mighty raccoon and subscribe to us click
that notification bell I like to end
this with a patron of the day shout out
to a woman named Anissa of liver it's uh
has her own YouTube channel right now
does reaction she's been such a
sweetheart now Anissa if all three
Joker's were in the room with you they
would all be clamoring for your
attention and doing whatever they can to
try to win your heart
John mmm considering that you are and
missus crush I'm gonna ask that you say
a pick-up line in each Joker voice to
Vanessa to the camera I don't look to me
for approval or reassurance start with
whomever you want but you got it do all
three
mmm Manisa all that chit chats gonna get
you a date with me
hahaha one down easiest one down hey hey
um ooh hey he a hole aha
you want to know how I got these scars I
I'm just so I'm just ya know it's it's
coming it's coming I'm working it up I'm
getting in character you go stop
distracting me okay all I have are
negative thoughts no that's not a good
joke I'm trying to come up with
something but it's like there's there's
endless time now in the camera oh you
could say you want to see a magic trick
I'm gonna make this paint no and then
the third one I'm gonna make my penis up
here hey lady goes I was thinking of the
opposite way to mark this play hmm
oh yeah that's right hey Aneesa when you
introduce me could you call me sexy
lover man I don't know call me lover can
you call me lover
hey and we even get an it reference in
there too if you want that so all right
we've done it this chairs rotating